est ce que tout le monde va partir à las
vegas où est ce qu'il y aura deux
équipes
il me faut également est-ce que mokhtari
la mokhtar merci et bien sachez que les
trois gagnants ont décidé je vous le dis
mes chéris
tout le monde part à des grues
[Applaudissements]
tout ce qui va se passer
vegas puisque on parlera léché bon état
il est kaboul est ici et nadège ici
allégé régis anouilh ça c'est vrai qu'il
veut pas
à dix jours du tour c'est mon chéri tu
allais j merci ma chérie c'est bon c'est
bon c'est mon dada touchée elle me donne
des peluches des miss a fini à mathieu
de la morale et du cabinet bradja duché
maire jean grenet il s'appelle pas
univoque vous demande en hausse il me
propose d'aller sur ces motards le seul
but du connacht